all right Lynn yes Lynn where are you
from originally New York what part
Huntington Long Island oh okay tell me
about your family growing up uh I had
one sister and a mom and dad
and a grandmother and a great aunt
grandfather and uncle
and a great uncle
how would you describe your childhood
my childhood was really good
um
I um I went to school all the time
I was very interested in staying in
school I was an athlete
um
I collected dolls I had uh what was your
sport bowling
and uh um
field hockey
and uh volleyball
you know we did sports during school and
stuff so good childhood yeah I did I had
a really good job you didn't go through
anything rough
no abuse or anything like that no no no
no no my family my dad was a police
officer my mom was a nurse back to an
extra technician so they were in the you
know she was in the medical field he was
in you know in in the police department
field and so
um my sister she had a job and
um she got married at a
you know when she met her High School
[__] boyfriend
and she moved Colorado
did you finish school did I yeah yeah I
graduated high school and I went to uh
Bradford State University which is
upstate New York
to college for a year
what'd you want to do
I wanted to be uh I wanted to be a
dietitian and gym teacher
because I was more in the sports field
so I need to do combine the both like a
major and a minor is that what you ended
up doing with your life
well now I wanted to go back being a
truck driver
actually yeah
you've been driving a truck yeah how
long do you drive a truck 25 years
but it's hard to get back in the
industry right now
I was working on it and then things fell
apart
so now you're pushing a card on on Skid
Row yeah how long you been here thank
you bro uh 22 27 years
it's a rough roughly to spend 20 years I
know but I was housed but it was it was
very conducive
and you're just on the street now
I'm on street now
just temporarily because I got my SSI in
my state disability reinstated and my
SSA also
I'm just waiting to get paid on Thursday
night but you know kind of ran out of
money in between
so I gotta do my little bit of recycling
because sometimes you tell you can't
have any cash anyway
so my little recycling job you can have
a little bit of cash without getting
rained by them
so I joined up on the street
um
how'd you end up on Skid Row basically I
knew it was good bro because uh
um I was overseasing Guam
and I was pregnant my youngest daughter
and I didn't know I was
and I flew back to the States the
Salvation Army program
and then after a couple days I found out
I was pregnant with my daughter that's
only for the adult rehab that was in
Pasadena so they had to transfer me to
towards Anna
which for women and children
and then things got way messed up and I
went to the Foley house and things got
way messed up and all that so
you're using white alcohol or drugs no I
just drink alcohol I did a beer and a
little bit of vodka once in a while
that's about it has that been a problem
in your life huh has that been a problem
for you no
no it's everybody else smoking a Pookie
and everything else you know all around
me and they keep walking past me and it
kind of you know it affects me
you know because I can't get around them
you know because it's hard to find a
spot to lay down somewhere without the
district telling you got to get up and
moved or the police department then you
got a good remove you know you're using
the shade you're in the Sun and it's
only temporary until I get paid on
Thursday night which
I'm trying to buy my time here
because I got two puppies out in order
they're really adorable too you have
kids huh you have a daughter
I have one daughter yeah
and that's the only child
the only one slept yeah
you lost somebody else yeah I lost my
son and lost my youngest daughter
but I still haven't started how'd you
lose the other two
uh the state took him
that was because of your your alcohol
no because I'm a billion trillionaire
if you want to know the truth
I don't know I ended up like that but
I'm dodging the bull with these people
if you have so much money why are you
living like this
why am I living off this why are you
living like this if you're
if you're close I have to get in I can't
get it it's a cash reserved from the
[__] Trump Administration
somehow and so I really can't use it but
they keep God like they keep attacking
me for it and all these other entities
you know
some hard time with it
that makes sense yep all right what's
the hardest part of living down here as
a female
hardest part about being
a female and having to drag my stuff
around
yeah you're pushing a big cart I know
I don't have a choice right now you have
a place to stay you don't have any tent
or anything like that no I can't live in
a tent it drives me nuts
I mean I tried it it's like ooh no I
can't have anything on my head and it's
hard to find anywhere else out there but
I'm gonna go get me I'm gonna try and
get me an apartment somewhere or you
know something but I'm gonna get my
puppies wherever they are now kissing uh
fixing uh South San Pedro having two
dogs and a cart huh having two dogs and
a cart but no home oh no I'm gonna get
rid of the cart
tell me to get us an apartment
because I'm gonna get some motel room or
something you know
with my income
Lynn what's your biggest regret in your
life my biggest regret
is that a dad I didn't pursue all the
indictments of people that stole my
identity
that I didn't pursue any of that
and I let them get away with it
if you know what I mean
does your daughter know that you're
living down here
yes she does
she's not trying to help you
she's lit like she's like my battery
Opera doll
she's what she's like my battery Opera
doll
what does that mean is she like my
morbid you know what a morph it is I
don't no no she's a morphed
she follows me around
he follows you around how huh what do
you mean she follows you around she just
does she's a stuffed doll
meaning she's an actual person or this
is just an imaginary daughter you have
no they have everywhere
she talks to me it's like she used to
follow me around with the pink scooters
she's in my shopping cart I just put the
batteries in her and then she starts
talking to me
I'm not that crazy don't think I'm not
you think I am but I don't know
how do you make money huh how do you
make money to survive
for my exercise teach disability my SSA
that's Gotta Wait for payday you got
another item between into recycling
it was the best I can do just have a
little bit of spending cash
you get robbed or anything like that
down here you get in trouble just
sometimes
no they try since I had in my shopping
basket
and I gotta smack him around this guy
gave me a nice big club today this
morning he said you need to keep this
foreign
what was the hardest part of your life
hardest part in my life
let's see
who's my dad
you're close to your dad
yeah
and my husband
I'm a kid
you've lost everybody yeah
really everything
all right
I still got my vessel
she had your life to live all over again
what would you have done differently
and Kimberly
and we started smoking crack cocaine
how's your back then in New York it was
pretty based
but then again
it's like it was like a glamor stroke
you know back in the back in the the 70s
I mean if you didn't have like if you're
gonna have a little bit of a pound of
cocaine on you really you weren't really
you know I mean
it was prestigious drug
but then again you know just
all right
what do you go through emotionally
living down here you get depressed
no I get really mad you get angry yeah I
do
because it would follow me around you're
like plugging me into their cars and
stuff like that they're just being mean
you know for no reason because they
don't know me that well
I mean I don't attack them my mom my old
business I do my own thing they always
want to come and start being smart asses
with me
for no reason
you have any friends down here
I have some friends that I run into from
uh my own apartment building
I ran into them
I mean I don't hang out with them but we
say hi to each other
what's your biggest fear now the biggest
fear
then my walk out there and we'll get hit
the beating Sun
I have to walk all the way out to
recycling which I'm gonna have to do
anyway
are you self-destructive no I'm so I'm
independent Let's Help discipline
and I'm very stubborn I'm a Capricorn I
get things done no matter what because
sometimes it feels like you really can't
do it and then you got I gotta look at
my you know my eye made and my iliac my
cognitive and say we gotta get up and go
now you know sleeping in front of
somebody's business so I forgot to get
up and go now well we might feel like it
or not and we got to keep going you know
you're very resilient people
what's your greatest strength very
straight
is my discipline
how do you think the decades you've
spent on the streets have has changed
you
has it changed me Made Me Stronger but
don't kill you make it stronger you know
you learn a lot
you know because they say that the
average American is one paid check away
from being homeless
and that's a true fact
no but you just don't walk out of being
in your in a nice house you know you
know live in the suburbs all of a sudden
you know you lost your job and you got a
family and you can't afford Starbucks
Coffee anymore you know we went through
all that with the disease and stuff you
just don't walk out and be successful as
being homeless
I mean it's it's it it takes a lot of
prestige it takes a lot of intelligence
and a lot of
um experience you just don't walk out of
your house and become successful being
being homeless
yeah there's a lot of things you need to
learn I'm yeah you do you just didn't
walk out and you know like and be people
you know you know because they've been
out there for how many years and you've
been in there living high in hog
driving by and laughing at us and stuff
like walking into a snake pit huh it's
like walking into a snake oh yeah oh
yeah it is but you know what but they
made fun of us up so many years you know
because when they came out with the
coronavirus we were like the United
States Marines I mean I'm like clearly
cheap in the United States I mean if we
guard the front line when they close
down their businesses we laid there on
the front line and guard their inventory
so the looters didn't get them you know
when they close down their businesses
and they couldn't open their businesses
we laid out there in front of their
businesses and guarded all their stuff
and they turn around and call us names
and treat us like crap the shoes are
like funny
did the same thing through the pandemic
same thing with the cover 19.
what do you think people don't
understand about people that are living
on the streets what do you think they
don't stand
I don't know
but
I know that they they go through your
stuff when you live inside
the scanners come in they scan all your
stuff they just do it because I've lived
inside I know how it is
sometimes the teacher out on the side
outside that is on the inside
so you in the past you smoked crack
oh I haven't in the past
you try anything else
no
an alcohol is your thing now yeah
can you quit if you wanted to
I could if I wanted to
I don't feel like it right now
I just got me some beers as a matter of
fact I need to go drink one
because it's hot
how old are you 62. what would you say
is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
I'm not putting lessons it's don't let
them stomp on you you know what goes
your own comes around and eventually you
know what you keep pissing me off I'm
gonna piss you off right now I'm gonna
piss on you
all right Lynn thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you good luck
out here